This lecture is a continued discussion
of generative probabilistic models for
text clustering.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue talking about the tax capture
text clustering, particularly
generative
probabilistic models.
So this is a slide that you have seen
earlier where we have written down the
likelihood function for a document.
With two distributions in two component
mixture model for document clustering.
Now in this lecture, we're going to
generalize this to include the K
clusters.
Now if you look at the formula and
think about the question how to
generalize it, you will realize that
all we need is to add more terms like
what you have seen here.
So you can just add more thetas and
the probabilities of thetas and the
probabilities of generating D from
those thetas.
So this is precisely what we're going
to use.
This is general presentation of the
mixture model for document clustering.
So as more cases we follow these steps
using a generated model.
First think about our data, right?
So in this case our data is a
collection of documents N documents
denoted by the sub I.
And then we talk about the model.
Think about the model.
In this case, we design a mixture of K
unigram language models.
It's a little bit different from the
topic model.
But we have similar parameters.
We have a set of theta i's denote the
word distributions corresponding to the
K unigram language models.
We have P of each theta I as the
probability of selecting each of the K
distributions to generate the document.
Now note that, although our goal is to
find the clusters and we actually have
used a more general notion of a
probability of each cluster.
And this, as you see later, would allow
us to assign a document to the.
Cluster that has the highest probability
of being able to generate the
document.
So as a result, we can also recover
some other interesting.
Properties.
As you will see later.
So the model basically would make the
following assumption about the
generation of the document.
We first choose a theta I according to
probability of theta I and then generate
all the words in the document using
this distribution.
Note that it's important that we use
this distributed generator.
All the words in the document.
This is very different from topic
model, so the likelihood function would
be like what you are seeing here.
So the.
You can take a look at the formula
here.
We have used the different.
Notation here in the second line of
this.
Of this equation.
But you can see now the.
notation has been changed to use unique
word in the vocabulary in the product
instead of particular position in the
document.
So from X sub J to W is a change of
notation, and this change allows us to
show the estimation formulas more
easily and you have seen this change
also in the topic model presentation,
but it's basically still just a product
of the probabilities of all the words.
I and so with the lack of functioning.
Now we can talk about how to do
parameter estimation.
Here we can simply use the maximum
likelihood estimator, so that's just a
standard way of doing things, so all
should be familiar to you now, it's
just a different model.
So after we have estimate the parameters,
how can we then allocate clusters to
the documents?
Let's take a look at this situation
more closely, so we just repeated the
parameters here.
For this mixture model.
Now, if you think about what we can get
by estimate such a model, we can
actually get more information than what
we need for doing clustering, right?
So theta.
I, for example, represents the content
of class I.
This is actually a byproduct.
It helps summarize what the cluster is
about to look at the top terms in this
cluster or in this word distribution.
And they will tell us what the cluster
is about.
An P of theta i can be interpreted as.
Indicating the size of cluster because
it tells us how likely cluster would be
used to generate the document.
The more likely a cluster is used to
generate the document, we can assume
the larger the cluster size is.
Note that unlike in PLSA and this
probability of theta I is not dependent
on D.
Now.
You may recall that the topic choice in
each document actually depends on D.
That means each document can have a
potentially different choice of topics,
but here we have a generic choice
probability for all the documents.
But of course, given a particular
document that we still have to infer
which topic is more likely.
To generate the document so in that
sense, we can still have a document
dependent probability of clusters.
So lets look at a key problem of assigning document to clusters or assigning clusters to documents
Lets to compute the C sub D here and this will take one
of the values in the range of one to k to
indicate which cluster should be
assigned to D.
Let's first you might think about a way
to use likelihood only, and that is
to assign D to the cluster
corresponding to the topic Theta I.
That most likely has been used to
generate D.
So that means we're going to choose one
of those distributions that gives D
highest probability.
In other words, we see which
distribution has a content that matches
our D best.
Intuitively, that makes sense.
However, this approach does not
consider the size of clusters, which is
also available to us.
And so a better way is to use the likelihood
together with the prior.
In this case the prior is P of Theta I.
And together, that is, we're going to
use the base formula to compute the
posterior probability of Theta given D.
And if we choose theta based on this
posterior probability and we would have
the following formula that you see
here.
On the bottom of this slide, and in
this case, we're going to choose the
theta that has a large P of Theta I.
That means a large cluster and also a
high probability of generating D.
So we're going to favor a cluster that's
large and also consistent with the
document.
And that intuitively makes sense
because the chance of a document being
a large cluster is generally higher
than in a small cluster.
So this means once we can estimate the
parameters of the model, then we can
easily solve the problem of document
clustering.
So next we have to discuss how to
actually compute the estimate of the
model.